all right so Pop Quiz Hank do you know
what this is good morning Hank it's
Tuesday so I'm at the Indiana medical
history museum in like the room where
they would do the autopsies where all
the students could watch because we're
filming a new kind of Crash Course where
we take a deep dive into one particular
topic and you'll never guess what my one
particular topic is unless you guess
it's the oldest deadliest and in my
opinion least understood infectious
disease in human history
tuberculosis hanky pointed out on your
video announcing that you had cancer
that lymphoma was originally believed to
be a type of tuberculosis which makes
sense because they have some similar
symptoms right night sweats fevers
sometimes you get coughing with both
yeah
not as young as I used to be this is an
iron lung for infants who got polio
that's the little mattress this is a
very helpful thing for me to look at
because it reminds me that progress is
possible Laboratories have come a long
way in the last hundred years they sure
have oh I didn't know that you would be
here yeah no I'm always here right I
guess that is kind of the issue wherever
I go I bring myself with me the other
symptom that TBN lymphoma have in common
of course is swollen lymph nodes in the
case of TB when it invades the lymphatic
system it's called scrofula and it can
actually cause the lymph nodes to become
so swollen that they rupture through the
skin good God TV sucks I know all right
let's go get a check of the weather I
think I know you're a microscopy
Enthusiast so I just wanted to make sure
you got to see this fella people are
always like oh we're the worst and sure
but look how hard we've worked to get
better I'll let you in on a little
secret the 30-foot microphone cord now
never stops being funny to me it's the
funniest thing in the world is it is it
going to be enough
it's close
but I made it by the way I'm not going
to explain all these costume changes
initially I thought this graffiti said
sad time and I liked it more because you
know it is kind of a sad time but right
the weather report yeah it's a nice day
let's talk about swollen lymph nodes so
years turned out to be lymphoma which of
course is is not ideal almost all the
time when you have swollen lymph nodes
it's no big deal you may not even feel
sick it's just your body kind of dealing
with an infection but in your particular
case
not great but people who swollen lymph
nodes turn out to be TB also have a
significant problem of course especially
if it ruptures and it wasn't that long
ago Hank that at least in Europe it was
widely believed that the number one most
reliable cure for scrofula was wait for
it
being touched by the king it was called
The King's touch the king would like
touch your head or else your wound and
then you would be magically cured
because of course the king got healing
powers through his direct Apostolic line
that that could trace all the way back
to Jesus if you're ever in Indianapolis
you have to go to the Indiana medical
history museum it's just awesome being
here reminds me that yes history is a
nightmare from which I am trying to
awaken Stephen detta was famously put it
but it's also much else history can also
be an encouragement we no longer treat
scrofula through the king's touch which
I would argue is good news on a few
levels both because we no longer think
kings are that powerful and because we
now have much better treatments so you
Hank I'm not gonna lie I'm super pissed
off that you got cancer but I am really
grateful to the people who accumulated
and shared and built upon each other's
knowledge so that we we could share a
better and healthier World 300 years
from now I hope we look back on a lot of
things the way today we look back on the
king's touch Hank I'll see you on Friday
hopefully but if you're not feeling good
that's fine no worries